(music)
Anne: American cinema was born in 1893.
The first film that we know of was called
The Blacksmithing Scene.
It's a 30 second black and white short,
called in actuality a brief
recording of an event.
20 years into the future in 1913
you begin to see the dawn of the narrative
film with the film Suspense directed
by Lois Weber and Philips Smalley.
It's the story of a young
mother and she lives
in a very remote area
in a home that is also
managed by their house maid.
We look at this film for the complexity
of the story telling.
We begin to see story
progressed through editing.
One day the maid just decides to quit.
She leaves the mother and the baby alone.
The husband is in the
city and he's working.
Then she takes the house
key and puts it under
the doormat.
The camera cuts to the maid walking along
the desolate road.
And a vagrant passes the
maid as she's leaving
the house.
You then see the vagrant
walk up to the house
and pick up the key.
The mother then looks out the window,
sees the vagrant with the key.
She knows that trouble is coming.
What Lois Weber and Philips Smalley
did that's really fascinating in terms
of film production was to
create a superimposition
of a triangle on the screen
and in the center is the husband
who receives a phone call from his wife.
You see the wife on one
angle of the triangle
and then you see the vagrant
at the door with the key.
So what you're seeing is this simultaneity
of action that was
never experienced before
by the audience.
The story goes on and becomes a chase.
The husband gets the phone call.
He steals a car along the way,
which then engages the
local police to chase him.
So you have this suspenseful moment
in what's going on in the house.
The mother is hiding with the baby.
You have the vagrant walking through
the house.
He's eyeing the various
valuables in the house,
and you have the father who is
trying to come to the rescue.
Ultimately the film ends up with the dad
rescuing the mother and
the child and the vagrant
being taken off to prison.
Pretty advanced stuff for 1913.